there once was a time when the left were
the champions of freedom remember the
60s fight for women's liberation civil
rights the explosion of creativity and
music and fashion and art of course not
all the consequences turned out to be
good but it was undeniably a powerful
and heartfelt expression of freedom
those revolutions were driven by young
people and they were overwhelmingly on
the left but look whether left is today
instead of freedom they stand for
control
they are the new Puritans marching
around telling everybody off for the way
they behave you can barely say word
these days without some joyless leftist
martinet pooping off about being unsafe
or triggered or culturally appropriated
or whatever the latest Orwellian epithet
is about sexism or racism or transphobia
of course sexism and racism and
transphobia are wrong but the way you
fight those things is through judicious
thoughtful and considered activism not
the brain-dead mind control tactics of
the new Puritans on the left and the
left today is not just puritanical it's
tyrannical they tell you what you're
allowed to think what you're allowed to
do what you're allowed to say if you
transgress you're shamed punished
destroyed in some cases they bang on
endlessly about diversity and then
proceeded to crush the most important
diversity of all the diversity that is
the foundation of human progress
diversity of thought there is no freedom
of thought of speech of anything on the
left these days only conformity a
miserable joyless conformity as the new
Puritans impose their intolerant bigoted
narrow-minded worldview on everybody
else
the left's new Puritans are taking over
the Democratic Party and imposing their
identitarian attitude on everything
there they'll probably nominate one of
their own is their presidential
candidate in 2020 and deservedly lose
because Americans love freedom they hate
being told what to do that's why America
was founded in the first place is why
America became the greatest country in
the history of the world young people
especially hate being told what to do
there's bound to be a revolt against the
left's authoritarianism intolerance so
while the Democrats
think they're Puritan takeover is good
politics today it will come back and
bite them in the end because the
instinct for freedom is deep and strong
an especially heartfelt in young people
if the left carries on with its
authoritarian pure it is immobilized
Chiefs I predict a riot now I'd love to
know what you think please follow us at
Steve Hilton X and at next Rev fnc